I'd say the answer to this question is
definitely yes role models are a very
intriguing part for what will make the
Middle East in the near future nurse
Innes for miles in particular who really
serves a great example for the youth of
the middle is today some of these
include His Majesty King Abdullah whose
balance moderation with his taking of
Western ideals and combining it with the
cultural aspects of Middle East make for
great output in Jordan and also other
examples include pusieras avadi the
foreign minister be a dog and the
president barack jalal talabani who also
serve as great ball miles for people in
that arrangement it's basically it
really does it comes down to the fact
that seventy percent of the Middle East
is now made up of you and therefore what
serves as an example to them is a very
horrible will make the Middle East as a
pole in the near future